-It has now been
almost four months
since Hurricane Maria devastated
the island of Puerto Rico,
leaving millions
without electricity
and clean drinking water.
Since then, the crisis
has all but completely
dropped out of the news cycle,
so we thought we'd see how
recovery efforts are proceeding.
It's time for "The Check In."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hurricane Maria was the worst
natural disaster on record
to hit Puerto Rico,
a fact seemingly lost
on our president,
who almost immediately
gave himself a perfect score
on handling the crisis.
-I'd say it was a 10.
I give ourselves a 10.
We have provided so much,
so fast, I would give a 10.
-I bet young Donald Trump
wasn't one of those kids
you let grade his own homework.
[ Light laughter ]
"What would you give yourself
on your volcano project?"
"An A-plus.
It's a great volcano.
Very lifelike."
"Really?
Because all you did was dip
a roll of toilet paper
in kerosene
and light it on fire."
Now, those 10 out of 10 comments
were made back in October.
So what's that perfect score
look like since then?
-Many Puerto Ricans spent
their first Christmas since
Hurricane Maria without power.
More than three months
after the storm,
the island's electrical grid
is operating
just 65% -- 65% -- of capacity.
The ongoing crisis there
is taking a terrible toll.
-The challenges
that they're facing,
particularly
in the remote areas,
rural areas, smaller towns,
are much the same now
as they were then.
-What we're seeing is really
a lowering of the bar
of what kinds of basic services
are American citizens
entitled to?
You know, it's gonna be 100 days
without electricity
for more than half
of this U.S. territory.
-If that's what Trump
considers a 10,
what would a 9 be?
Accidentally sending
an outbreak monkey?
"Okay, I'll be honest.
We sent a monkey
to help with the cleanup.
It had a deadly virus.
Long story short,
9 out of 10."
[ Light laughter ]
But don't worry, Puerto Rico.
The president might not
be on the case,
but there's still Ben Carson.
He's a brain surgeon,
took a Hippocratic oath,
and he's the Secretary
of Housing
and Urban Development.
Surely, he had something
a little more helpful
to say about this crisis.
Here he is being asked how long
he thought HUD was going to be
in Puerto Rico.
-Any idea how many years?
-Somewhere between 1 and 100.
[ Both laugh ]
[ Laughter ]
-Ben Carson might be the first
brain surgeon in history
to leave a sponge
inside his own head.
"So as you can see
from your x-ray,
everything is fine.
Mine, on the other hand..."
[ Laughter ]
Now, to give you
a sense of the dysfunction
in the recovery efforts,
a contract for hundreds
of millions of dollars
was afforded to a small company
in Whitefish, Montana --
which also happens
to be the hometown
of interior secretary
Ryan Zinke --
to help restore
Puerto Rico's electrical grid.
But almost immediately,
there was scrutiny
over the contract.
First of all, the company
only had two employees
when Hurricane Maria hit.
Two employees
to handle a Hurricane!
That's like trying
to solve Afghanistan
with the Mayberry
Police Department.
Now, after much outcry
and overbilling issues,
the Whitefish contract
has since been canceled,
but Puerto Rico is still
desperately in need of help.
In November, for example,
the White House asked Congress
for $44 billion
in hurricane aid --
funds designated
for Texas and Florida.
Even worse, Trump and the GOP
passed a tax plan
that disproportionately harms
Puerto Ricans
by treating
the American territory
as a foreign entity
and imposing unfair
and cruel taxes on them
which could result in the loss
of hundreds of thousands
of jobs there.
-Congress has just passed
this tax bill
which had this really sinister
effect, if I may,
on Puerto Rico.
-It has an insidious,
pernicious effect
on manufacturing in Puerto Rico.
-It puts an excise tax,
an import tax,
on products and services
for Puerto Rico.
-A tax that's not there now.
-That's not there now.
-That would cripple
the Puerto Rican economy.
-Well, it's crippled already.
It will obliterate it.
This would be a much more
devastating blow to our economy
than Irma and Maria
put together.
-The Republican tax bill
is worse
than two Hurricanes
put together.
In fact,
that's how meteorologists
are going to start
classifying them from now on.
[ Laughter ]
Perhaps the only thing Trump
has actually succeeded in doing
when it comes to Puerto Rico
is diverting attention
away from the crisis.
Over the weekend,
the news cycle was dominated
by Trump's alleged remarks
that countries like Haiti
and African nations
are [bleep]holes,
which the governor
of Puerto Rico
also had to respond to.
-I think it is
an S-H-I-T-T-Y comment.
It is completely unacceptable.
-I get it.
He's spelling it
so that Trump wouldn't
understand what he's saying.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Call the NSA.
I need our very best
code breaker on this."
[ Laughter ]
But Trump's comments
are indicative
of his lackluster response
to Hurricane Maria.
From the very beginning,
he treated
the American citizens
of Puerto Rico much differently
than those in Florida and Texas.
And that's alarming,
considering Puerto Rico
was already facing
a brutal recession
before the hurricanes hit
that left 44% of the population
impoverished.
And now, instead of actually
helping
the people of Puerto Rico,
Republicans and Trump
passed a law
that would exacerbate
the already dire
economic situation there.
And that can only be described
as, really --
What's the word I'm looking for?
-S-H-I-T-T-Y.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the one.
This has been "The Check In."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]